what is going on everybody my name is
malik prince and november 10th is right
around the corner so you know what that
means
the launch of the xbox series x our
fastest most powerful console ever
and the xbox series s our smallest xbox
ever packed with next-gen performance
they're both right around the corner
super exciting time so today what we're
going to do is we're going to walk you
through a full demo
from top to bottom unedited to showcase
the entire experience
on a full retail unit by the way just
like the one you get on launch but of
course i can't do it alone so with me
from the xbox engineering team
it is harrison hoffman harrison how are
you doing great how you doing malik
i'm pumped i'm excited it's a new
generation of games we got assassin's
creed valhalla on the on the horizon
cyberpunk thing coming out um it's a
great time to be a gamer absolutely
um so we're gonna get started in just a
second but just want to a quick note
that the even though we're showcasing
the xbox series x today
um we also have the xbox series s here
and with both of these consoles we're
really talking about
faster load times higher frame rates and
richer more dynamic worlds and so you're
gonna see that today
um but harrison i'm a mind reader i can
tell the comments are gonna be
get into it already so let's do it let's
get into it all right let's not keep
them waiting let's turn this thing on
boom here we go exciting time for the
team so much work has gone into this i
bet you're pumped
oh yeah i mean the team's been working
on these consoles for for years at this
point so you know we're all just really
really excited to
for gamers all around the world to get
their hands on it i love it i love it so
first thing we notice when you turn on
the console it's home of course
uh so let's walk through what's new here
first thing here you know the the team
has really spent um
a lot of time over the last year plus
really you know simplifying
optimizing refining the the experience
on on xbox here to really make it one um
you know simpler more accessible for
people who are new to xbox who might not
have ever had an xbox console before and
then two
um to make it a lot more powerful and
useful for people who are those
upgraders and those kind of loyal little
xbox gamers so
when i land here on home really really
the intention of home is to give you
quick access to the games that you were
playing recently as well as
can i give you um easy ways to discover
new games to play um
yeah yeah and i'd be remiss if i didn't
call it these sick dynamic backgrounds
that i see going on here what's up with
that for sure so this is uh exclusive to
xbox series x and s these are our new
dynamic backgrounds here we have one for
each color that you can pick on the
system uh and we're hoping to add more
in the future too
love that looking forward to that so um
obviously launch day people are probably
going to
want to play a game or two on their
console so uh what do you want to play
first
let's let's jump into something yeah uh
let's just dive straight into gears 5
here i think that's a good place to
start
very good choice very good choice and um
the big reason why
i wanted to start with this this game
here you know this is obviously a game
from the xbox one generation and it was
you know
really like a visual showcase of the
time really really stunning game
and the coalition has done a lot of
great work to really
make this game shine on xbox series x
and s so they've you know
gone and done all the optimization work
for it we see this game now running at a
beautiful you know 4k
60 here here in the campaign and it's
just looking better than ever before
uh one thing to to really call your
attention to here are
the the detail of the textures and
that's because we are actually using
the same textures that we use in the pc
version of gears 5 when it's running
under
under ultra settings and that's
something that we that we couldn't do
before on xbox one x but now we're able
to do on xbox series x
um so it's really really great to see
the game just looking phenomenal here
and then versus multiplayer that frame
rate's going all the way up to 120 right
so that was actually one of the first
things that i did when i got access to
this this version of gears and i fired
up the versus multiplayer just to see
what the 120 frames per second really
feels like and
i think a lot of people can really
relate to that jump from from 30 to 60
um and really being able to feel the
difference there and then going from 60
to 120 it just feels
like incredibly smooth it's kind of like
a gameplay experience like i've never
had before honestly nice well i just
upgraded my tv so i'm excited to check
that out
um all right so maybe you're playing
gears and you want to check in what your
friends are up to or maybe start at
parties let's let's check out the guide
what's going on here
yeah so um all you have to do here is
just hit the xbox button and it just
pulls up the guide and
you can just think of this as our you
know sort of over game menu so it can
come up over the top of
any game that you're you're playing on
the system here and gives you quick
access to those things you might want to
do while you're actually playing a game
so
you know being able to quickly switch
between your games and apps check out
your notifications
you know take a look at your friends
list your party chats your messages your
achievements um and really kind of
having all that at your fingertips
without disrupting the game at all i
love it let's uh let's hit up another
game uh what do you what do you want to
play well i think we've gotta dive into
dirt five next
let's do it uh dirt five yeah for sure
very beautiful game for sure uh
first thing that i want to call your
attention to is we're transitioning here
is this little quick resume icon at the
top
and this is a brand new feature that we
have for siriusxms and what quick resume
does is it allows you to instantly
pick up where you left off across
multiple games in the system so
i mean if you're like me you know like
i'm playing you know three or four games
probably probably at a time maybe
someone playing with my friends
someone's maybe like a more serious game
i'm
i'm playing by myself maybe there's kind
of a more casual game i like to jump
into occasionally
and i can have all those games like hot
and ready to play here so
just quick resuming into dirt five like
i'm just right back here in the middle
of the race
um and everything's just looking
phenomenal yeah i feel like a broken
record but this is stunning when you get
a console on launch i feel like racing
games do such a great job
of showcasing and you see like the cars
the reflections the dirt
let's name the game flying everywhere
it's just a really cool a really cool
showcase of next gen
um but of course we've talked about this
game being on series x and series s
let's go back in time big focus on xbox
has been compatibility um so let's
showcase a back and back game what do
you want to showcase so let me pop up in
the guide again
um let's just jump over to subnautica
which um
it's a great game from from xbox one as
well and
um one thing you're going to notice as
soon as we quick resume back back over
to this game
is that um these colors in this game are
looking
better than they've ever looked before
so let me just dive into the water here
and that's actually all thanks to a new
feature that we have a platform level
feature called auto hdr and this does
exactly what it sounds like and it adds
hdr to games that have never had it
before which is
like a crazy impressive feature and even
you know games for the xbox 360 for the
original xbox
you can go play fusion frenzy which was
a launch day game on the original xbox
in hdr
and it's just really kind of breathing
new life into these into these games um
and these fantastic classic games on
xbox fusion frenzy one of the first game
that i ever played on xbox so i'm
definitely excited to jump in
and that's what we've kind of been
talking about thousands of games across
four generations
um okay cool so i'm looking at this game
this is pretty awesome
and i also been checking out that
controller familiar but i know a few
tweaks to make it even better right
yeah for sure so this is the brand new
xbox wireless controller so this is
going to come with your xbox series x or
s when you get it it's also
um obviously available to purchase
separately and there's a few things that
you're going to notice when you when you
get this controller
um the first thing is that it feels
really really comfortable in your hands
so we've
taken everything that we've learned from
you know making the xbox one controller
listening to fans and feedback
doing a lot of testing with with real
people all around the world and
we've actually um slightly improved the
the ergonomics this controller made it
just like ever so slightly smaller
so it feels even more comfortable in
more people's hand sizes which is
awesome and really kind of making gaming
more accessible to more people which
which we love doing for sure love that
so the d-pad i know inspired by the
elite series two
yeah textured grips uh and on the
triggers and bumpers that's pretty cool
but i know
um one thing that i love to do is share
my experiences in the games even if
they're
terrible like they usually are in
multiplayer games um but i know it's
quicker than ever to share directly from
the xbox wires controller right
yeah for sure so uh right here on the
controller
we have a new button and it's called the
share button and it's super useful all i
have to do
is just tap it once to capture a
screenshot
or press and hold it to capture a game
clip and what this really does
is let me keep my focus on the games
when something awesome happens and i'm
like totally freaking out and i need to
actually capture that clip
um i don't have to take my attention
away from the game i don't have to go
into some other menu
i i just hit that share button right
there and it's automatically captured
nice and we've been talking about speed
a lot not only is it faster than ever to
actually take a clip or a screenshot
but also now it's faster to actually
share it to your friends on social media
right
yeah for sure so when it comes time to
share it um i really just go to my phone
i break up my phone so once i've
captured that clip it you know
automatically gets uploaded to xbox live
and is available for sharing
i'll get a notification right here on my
phone that says hey you've got you got a
new screenshot that's ready to share
and then i can just share that out to
any of my friends or networks that my
phone knows about like the phone is kind
of like the ultimate sharing tool like
it knows about you know all the
different places that i want to share
um so really i love that we're kind of
making this whole process seamlessly
completing that here
nice and then in that xbox app i know
there's new features it's been
redesigned
walk us through that um this is the new
xbox mobile app and we've actually um
totally rebuilt this app from the ground
up
in annotation in anticipation of the
series x xns launch
so this is actually the app that you're
going to use to set up your new console
on day one you're going to be able to
use it to log in your microsoft account
put in your wi-fi password
set up all your settings while your
console is taking that day one update
and then after that your console is
really like just
linked directly to your phone so now you
know i can just interact with my console
right right from my phone so
if i'm you know out anywhere in the
world and i you know get get really
really inspired about a particular game
that i want to go check out
i can go and search for it right here
and remotely download it to my console
so when i get home it's all ready to
play
um also if i don't you know if i just
can't wait until i
until i get home to play and i really
need to get some gaming in we also have
a brand new feature called remote play
which is awesome
and basically this lets you be able to
remotely play any game that's installed
on my console here um via the xbox app
and all i have to do
is just connect my xbox wireless
controller up to my phone and then i'm
just up and playing right here i love
that so your
experience with xbox doesn't end with
the tv in the console it extends your
phone and that is pretty dope
okay so let's find more games i know
xbox game pass is a great way to
discover your next favorite game
um and directly from home we actually
have content blocks and xbox game pass
is one of them so
let's talk about that so as i was saying
earlier really one of the things that we
want the dashboard and home to be able
to do
is to help you find that next thing to
play help you find that next game
so when you're kind of going around
looking for inspiration and you're
browsing around the dashboard
and game pass is a big part of that and
we've really built that into the
experience
and you know when i go down from the top
of home here see you can you can see the
game pass block
and you know you can check out all of
our featured titles what's been added to
the game pass catalog recently
when i click into it you sort of get the
full experience and get to look at
the full breadth of the catalog here um
be able to go in here
check out check out the details about
one of these games be able to kick it
off for for an install if it's if it's
looking cool
nice and of course on november 10th we
have a huge addition to xbox game pass
right yeah
on november 10th launch day for for
these consoles we are adding ea play
to xbox game pass ultimate um which
which gives you access to all those
games that
that are in the ea play catalog all the
games all the all the trials and you can
just play them right here if you have
ultimate so that give me access to
titanfall 2. it will give you access to
titanfall too harrison you just made my
day i'm super excited so of course if a
game is not an xbox game pass uh you
just want to purchase it then you go
over to the xbox store
which i hear has been redesigned of
course speed yeah definitely so i'll
just pop right into the store here
and um the first thing that we really
focus on with the new store
is speed and performance we wanted to
make sure that it is as fast as possible
for you to get into the store
and to you know be able to search for
games and and find something that you
want to play so you
you saw how how fast that launch you can
see as we're sort of going around here
how quick the user interface is to to
navigate here if i want to check out
more details about a game maybe i want
to see you know assassin's creed
valhalla
i can click into it check out check out
the details page here
see trailers information about the game
kind of everything that i need to decide
whether or not i want to buy it
nice and of course that speed also
translates to the download speech which
i hear
improved on both the consoles yeah uh we
have you know brand new advanced
networking hardware um
in both of these consoles that lets us
take more full advantage of your home
internet connection when you're
downloading games so
you're kind of not going to be bumping
up against those kind of um you know
hardware
restricted uh caps anymore on on those
downloads and we'll be able to kind of
more fully take advantage of that
connection
get you those games faster than ever
that is dope and of course to see all
your games
you would head over to my games and apps
which i know uh has improvements on
displaying the games but also
on showcasing where those games came
from right yeah definitely so
if i dive into my games and apps like
this is really you know where i go to
see all the games that are installed on
my console as well as kind of see the
games that i that i have access to as
well so
just sort of coming into here um these
are all the games that i have installed
here you can see
how fast all this is loading um you'll
also notice that
we have some badges on on some of these
tiles here
that tell you which subscription these
games are coming from so you see burnout
paradise stream master coming from ea
play
doom eternal um as well as the outer
worlds coming coming from game pass and
it's just really nice to be able to
scroll through here
and just kind of see exactly where
everything's coming from yep and all
those service
services obviously bring in more games
than ever and you may need
a little bit of extra space so a little
birdie told me that you have one of
those new seagate
storage expansions with you i do it is
right here so
uh this is the uh seagate one terabyte
storage expansion card and
i mean this thing is really just like a
marvel of engineering the first thing
that
the first time i saw this i was just
totally blown away so
full terabyte of storage right in here
it plugs directly into the back of the
console
and this storage is actually just as
fast as
you know our crazy fast nvme ssd that we
have inside the console so that means
that
you're going to get those same load
times you're you're going to get quick
resume you're going to get to be able to
um you know play xbox series x and s
games directly off of this drive but
then also there's an option
if maybe you need to store more games um
with the regular usb
right yeah for sure so um especially you
know if you're looking to play backwards
compatible games like xbox one xbox 360
or original xbox games
you can just plug in a usb hard drive
like you do today and play any of those
games off of here and then
you know save your your kind of faster
ssd storage um
for for the for those next gen games i
love that now that's the first time that
i'm seeing it and again you were right
it is a marvel of engineering
uh do you mind if i do the honors and
plugged it in absolutely there you go
okay here we go here we go everybody i
am
boom look at that i did it i did it and
that was
that was fast there you go again we've
been talking about speed this entire
time
and almost every part of this experience
is that and so harrison this has been
fantastic thank you for walking us
through this entire demo
and again on november 10th you're gonna
get xbox series x and series s
we're really focusing we've been talking
about it higher frame rates faster load
times
and richer more dynamic worlds and
thousands of games across generation
including assassin's creed valhalla as a
new game and cyberpunk later on
i'm super excited to play um this has
been great harrison let's just go back
and play some dirt though all right
let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
you